-Ce n'est pas le député
le plus suivi sur TikTok,
mais c'est sans doute celui
que les influenceurs
redoutent le plus,
car dans ce domaine
comme dans les autres,
mon invité a appliqué
sa propre méthode
avec sérieux et application.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Arthur Delaporte.
-Bonjour.
-Dans les portraits
qu'on lit sur vous,
des formules reviennent :
"Elève modèle", "Tête bien faite",
"Brillant".
Il y a cette expression
employée par Laurence Dumont,
la députée socialiste sortante,
qui vous a un peu transmis
sa circonscription,
on va en parler.
Elle vous a qualifié
de "Gendre idéal".
Comment est-ce que vous le prenez ?
Est-ce que c'est un compliment,
ou ça vous agace ?
-Venant de Laurence,
c'est toujours positif,
car c'est quelqu'un que j'apprécie.
-Dans cette expression,
il y a l'idée d'un jeune homme
trop parfait,
qui offre très peu d'aspérités,
du coup,
qu'on a un peu du mal à saisir,
à cerner,
alors j'ai envie de dire :
Arthur Delaporte, aidez-moi,
qui êtes-vous ?
-Qui suis-je ?
-"Répondez !"
Je suis député de la deuxième
circonscription du Calvados
depuis six mois,
mais avant, j'étais chercheur,
chercheur en sciences politiques.
-C'est ce qui vous convenait ?
-C'est l'expression d'une forme
de curiosité permanente sur tout,
sur le monde, et la volonté
de sortir du discours préconçu,
ou de ce qu'on impose au réel
pour analyser des phénomènes,
analyser les choses,
prendre du recul par rapport
à une image de façade
qui serait parfois trompeuse.
-Si je précise que vos deux parents
étaient instituteurs,
que vos quatre grands-parents
est-ce que ça aide à répondre
à cette question ?
Est-ce que quelque chose
qui a été déterminant, pour vous ?
-Disons que j'ai grandi
dans un milieu où l'éducation,
au sens large, était importante.
C'est une éducation populaire,
à la citoyenneté,
une éducation au monde
qui nous entoure,
et toujours cette idée
de la curiosité,
et on va dire à une certaine forme
d'optimisme par rapport aux choses.
C'était une éducation
qui était aussi
sur les nouvelles méthodes
pédagogiques.
C'est pas le coté devoirs, leçons.
C'est : les expériences,
mener des projets,
et on apprend aussi
par la découverte.
-Vous parents n'avaient pas
d'engagement politique,
mais tous les étés,
ils vous emmenaient
dans les campings
de la MAIF, façon kibboutz,
on va dire.
Vous avez aussi fait
votre première manif
à l'âge de quatre ans.
Il y a même un article,
on le voit ici.
Le bonhomme à côté
de la poussette, c'est vous.
Plus tard, vous êtes devenu
un peu le GO du lycée,
vous avez été le président
du foyer,
vous avez créé une radio,
vous avez créé, aussi, un journal.
Est-ce que vous faites le lien
entre tout ça
et votre engagement politique ?
-C'est sûr que quand on est amené
à s'engager, on va dire,
dans la vie de la cité
par différentes formes,
de toujours essayer
d'animer un collectif,
on finit aussi par se dire :
"Qu'est-ce que je peux apporter ?"
Quand on voit la politique,
- j'ai toujours été intéressé
par la politique -
je me suis dit :
"C'est peut-être
l'une des étapes qui arrive
"quand on a dynamisé des collectifs
toute sa jeunesse."
Ce que j'ai pris beaucoup de plaisir
à faire,
car c'était toujours
un esprit de solidarité,
comment on va vers les autres,
il y a cette dimension-là.
-Il y a votre éveil à la politique,
votre conscientisation
qui s'est faite très jeune.
A l'âge de 10 ans,
vous avez épluché les professions
de foi des candidats
à la présidentielle
et vous avez voté pour Taubira.
-A l'époque,
c'était un choix un peu marginal.
Ca l'est peut-être un peu resté.
J'avais regardé
les différentes professions de foi,
et son programme
était celui qui me parlait le plus.
Après, j'étais évidemment triste,
déçu et traumatisé par la défaite
de Lionel Jospin,
c'est resté comme quelque chose
d'extrêmement marquant.
-Mais aussi jeune, quoi.
-Oui, après, on parlait toujours
de politique, autour de moi.
Ce qu'on appelle
le milieu partisan
du Parti Socialiste
en sociologie politique,
c'est des enseignants,
qui sont investis
dans l'éducation populaire,
et qui vont en camping l'été,
notamment dans des campings
où on élit les responsables de camp,
qui sont propriété
de la collectivité.
-Si on regarde votre trajectoire,
ça ressemble presque
à un parcours sans faute.
Du côté des études,
vous avez fait Normale Sup, à Lyon,
en même temps que Sciences Po
à Paris,
et vous êtes agrégé d'histoire.
Et puis,
dans votre trajectoire politique,
vous avez été collaborateur
de député,
puis collaborateur de la présidente
du groupe PS
Valérie Rabault, ensuite, patron
de la fédération PS du Calvados,
puis, enfin, député,
et porte-parole
du groupe socialiste
à l'Assemblée nationale.
Ca donne l'impression
de quelque chose de très méthodique,
très rationnel,
dans votre ascension politique,
comme si vous aviez fixé
des marches à gravir une par une.
-Je sais pas si c'est des marches
à gravir,
parce qu'il y a aussi
des histoires de rencontres.
Quand je me suis engagé
au Parti Socialiste,
j'ai pris ma carte en 2013,
au moment du mariage pour tous,
Taubira.
Je me suis dit : "Je vais m'engager
pour lutter contre l'extrême droite,
"contre cette droitisation
du débat public
"et mener la bataille."
En même temps,
j'ai cherché à faire un stage,
et c'est après un refus
de Laurence Dumont,
qui me connaissait pas,
c'est Yann Galut,
député du Cher,
qui a accepté de me prendre
avec lui.
On était engagés dans un collectif
qui s'appelait La Gauche forte.
L'idée était de dénoncer
et d'être fiers de se dire :
"Je défends des valeurs,
"je dénonce
le Rassemblement National."
Ca a été le facteur
de mon engagement.
Après, on fait des rencontres.
-Il y a quand même
ce côté méthodique et sérieux
qui ressort.
-C'est ce qui peut en ressortir
derrière.
Je dirais pas
que je suis pas sérieux,
mais je pense
que la politique, on peut prendre
de la distance par rapport à ça.
C'est sérieux,
mais on peut ne pas l'être
dans son rapport aux gens.
-Vous laissez la place au hasard ?
-Il y avait du hasard.
J'étais pas sûr
de ce qui allait se passer.
C'est juste que de fil en aiguille,
Galut connaît quelqu'un, me dit :
"Elle aimerait te prendre
comme collaborateur."
Du coup, je bosse, on se rencontre,
je rencontre Valérie Rabault.
C'est une affaire de rencontres.
-Votre formation
de chercheur en histoire,
vous l'avez aussi
méthodiquement associée
à votre engagement politique.
Quand j'ai découvert vos sujets
de recherches,
je me suis mis à sourire.
Vous avez fait un mémoire consacré
au voyage de Mitterrand à Sofia,
vous avez fait une thèse
consacrée à la recomposition
des courants au sein du PS,
vous avez étudié la façon
dont la série "Baron noir",
consacrée au PS,
a été perçue par les militants,
les responsables
du Parti Socialiste.
Vous évoquiez Yann Galut,
vous avez dirigé sa campagne
aux législatives.
Quand vous avez pris ces fonctions,
vous avez fait un travail
de recherches sur la fédération PS
dans le département.
Ca veut dire quoi ?
-Ca veut dire que finalement,
la politique,
c'est quelque chose
qui est chronophage.
Moi, j'aimais aussi beaucoup
la recherche.
J'avais un matériau sous les yeux
qui était passionnant.
Le Parti Socialiste me questionnait
à la fois en tant que militant,
mais aussi en tant que chercheur.
C'était des moments
de recomposition.
Quand je suis arrivé,
je ne comprenais pas tout,
j'avais pas les codes.
Faire de la recherche était un moyen
de comprendre cette histoire,
cette culture,
et un moyen de gagner du temps
pour faire de la recherche
et en même temps de la politique.
Quand j'étais avec Yann Galut,
j'étais sans cesse sur les routes,
mais le midi, je m'arrêtais
chez un militant,
je faisais un entretien,
je passais le soir au siège
du Parti Socialiste,
j'explorais les archives
de la fédération.
Ca permettait de faire les deux :
d'être à la fois militant
le jour ou la nuit,
et puis chercheur
le jour ou la nuit, voilà.
-On va évoquer
votre activité en tant que député.
Je sais pas si Maeva Ghennam,
Nabilla
ou Seb La Frite regardent LCP,
mais il y a un député
dont ils connaissent le nom,
c'est vous.
Vous êtes à l'origine d'une loi
qui a donné
des sueurs froides aux influenceurs.
Regardez.
*-Hello, guys !
*-On va vous raconter ce qu'il s'est
passé à l'Assemblée nationale.
*-L'Assemblée nationale, guys.
*-Vu ma tête
et mes expressions du visage,
vous vous doutez bien
que ça ne s'est pas bien passé
pour moi.
Ils m'ont demandé
si j'avais déjà fait
des placements de produits
pour les paris sportifs.
*-OUI.
*-Pour la chirurgie esthétique.
*-Crypto, trading.
*-OUI.
*-Je me suis sentie
tellement honteuse.
*-Désolée, je me sens pas concernée.
*-On aurait dit
que les députés,
c'était mes pères.
-C'était Mélanight,
elle a 1 million d'abonnés
sur Instagram,
que vous avez reçue à l'Assemblée,
dans le cadre de cette proposition
de loi,
que vous aviez portée
avec Stéphane Vojetta,
qui a été adoptée,
proposition de loi
sur les influenceurs.
Vous l'avez traumatisée,
cette pauvre Mélanight.
-Après, je peux vous dire
qu'on n'a pas été méchants.
On voulait comprendre,
donc de discuter
avec des influenceuses,
ça fait partie
du parcours de la loi.
Quand on a dit : "Cette dérive-là,
ça vous est arrivé ?"
Elle a dit : "Oui...
"Je suis une repentie."
Tant mieux, c'est bien
qu'elle ait pris conscience
que ses actes avaient conduit
à des dérives,
que des influenceurs
s'en sont mis plein les poches.
Ces influenceurs sont minoritaires
mais ont fait n'importe quoi.
L'idée de la loi était d'arrêter
avec l'absence de cadre,
et de remettre un peu d'ordre
là-dedans.
Je pense qu'on va y arriver.
Il y a une prise de conscience
chez Mélanight, mais pas seulement.
Maeva Ghennam, par exemple,
elle a fait une story
où elle montre
qu'elle découvre l'amende
qui est faite,
jusqu'à 300 000 euros d'amende,
et là, elle fait : "Oh !"
Elle a un mouvement de recul.
Bah oui, c'est vrai,
il faut arrêter
de faire n'importe quoi.
-Cette loi, vous l'avez co-écrite
avec le député Renaissance
Stéphane Vojetta.
Le début de cette législature
a été marquée
par des tensions entre les députés.
Vous, vous faites copain-copain
avec un député de la majorité,
pour faire voter une loi
à l'unanimité,
quand même,
dans cet hémicycle très tendu.
C'est votre côté GO du lycée
qui ressort ?
-Je peux vous dire
que c'est pas fini, les tensions.
Aujourd'hui encore,
on a des tensions.
Je m'oppose au gouvernement
et à sa politique d'atrophisation
du débat démocratique.
Ce qu'on a voulu montrer,
c'est qu'une autre méthode
était possible,
où le Parlement
se saisissait des sujets.
J'ai commencé,
j'ai déposé mon texte fin décembre.
J'ai été contacté,
notamment par Stéphane Vojetta,
qui m'a dit :
"Je travaille sur le sujet."
-Vous avez uni vos forces.
-Le gouvernement soutenait
Stéphane Vojetta.
On avait envie de montrer
qu'on pouvait travailler
majorité comme opposition,
sans partir du même point de départ,
mais qu'on pouvait converger
par le respect mutuel.
-On va passer à notre quiz,
à présent.
Vous avez droit à un quiz spécial,
où vous allez dresser un palmarès
des meilleurs influenceurs
de l'Assemblée.
Il s'agit de juger
les prestations des députés
sur les réseaux sociaux.
On commence avec la catégorie
"Boss de la punchline".
Le ou la députée
qui vous impressionne
sur les réseaux sociaux ?
-Celui qui a les meilleures
punchlines à l'Assemblée
et qui devrait être plus fort
sur les réseaux,
c'est Boris Vallaud,
le président de mon groupe.
Il a un sens de la formule...
-Oh, c'est facile !
-En même temps, il est capable
de sortir des punchlines,
10 à la minutes.
-C'est sur les réseaux sociaux ?
-Il faut qu'il continue
à travailler un peu plus.
-On a ensuite la catégorie
"Roi ou reine du LOL".
L'humour est important,
en politique.
-Celui qui rigole beaucoup
sur les réseaux,
c'est Hadrien Clouet,
un député insoumis.
Il fait souvent des petites vidéos.
Il a une capacité
à prendre de la distance
par rapport au quotidien
et à faire rire les gens
qui est assez forte.
-Enfin, "The doc of TikTok".
Le ou la députée le plus pédago,
si on peut dire ?
C'est important, la pédagogie,
en politique.
-J'aime beaucoup
ma collègue écologique
Marie-Charlotte Garin.
Elle fait des vidéos sur TikTok
qui sont très pédago.
-Vous vous y êtes essayé.
-J'en fais aussi.
TikTok est un média
super intéressant
pour aller vers les jeunes
et leur montrer
l'Assemblée dans les coulisses,
de derrière,
et déconstruire un peu
les idées reçues,
tout en valorisant l'institution
au sens large,
car c'est un bel objet démocratique
qui est malheureusement trop dévoyé.
-Merci, Arthur Delaporte.
-Merci.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA